hey guys today we have this
2016 Dodge
Durango and they only have one smart key
fob we're going to be programming
another one this is the AEL
Universal and this is the
Durango RT as you can see Dodge Durango
so we have one working key faab and
we're going to make another one program
to it all right let get started
[Music]
all right first let's check if it's
working this one locks
unlocks and this is not
working yet so what we're going to do we
already to put battery inside of this
one
then first we're going to go
to AEL or let's go find what kind of
um FCC is
it let's go
to smart book right here it's going to
be a
Dodge I think it's right
here
no there you go Dodge
see check it again
Dodge okay it's not in here it's not
showing up let me clear that
up check it one more time here you go
Dodge
Chrysler and this is a
Durango
see hey go
Dodge Dodge
Durango 2016 so it's 14 to
21 that's a proximity page
48 I'm not reading it on page
48 there you
go page 48 so
all
right all the way to the
end okay this is the five buttons right
there and this
is the Rango 5 is a
m3n the last number is
1302 43 433 mahz
all right but going to the auto km
um we go Universal
key and this one is just going to go
to
dodge then this is
Durango and there two kinds that's why
we have to look for the frequence um FCC
ID a gq4 but this a m3n so we go
m3n so we have this I'm going to go
ahead put this in
here I'm going to go ahead generate
Universal
key so this one is going to generate it
it might take a little
minute so we're going to come back so
you can see
generating once it
generated we're going to go ahead start
programming all right this one is done
as you can see it says Universal key
generation is completed do you want to
continue the
generation if we
continue
see use the new Universal key then press
okay to continue the generation this is
if you want to generate another one so
we can cancel that one cuz we're done
what we're going to do is go ahead
program it to the
car go ahead we're going to use the km
100 let me hook up the
OBD underneath and then let's go ahead
program this all right so I'm
connected
this let's go ahead program this let's
see what we can do here maybe it's too
bright go
down
so over here let's go
ahead
MMO let me go ahead turn on the car
first one
two so I
more let's go inside so it doesn't beep
close the door there you go so let's go
ahead go to North
America this is a 2016 so it Go 16 to
17 smart key
yes if you have learn key turn on the
ignition yeah it's on just put it in a
run position press
okay it's
communicating
so let's go emo stle
scan going to go ahead read the system
first
make sure the turn on the ignition
engine is stop okay it's on
okay scanning the system right now real
quick make sure there's no engine light
or anything if everything is good we can
go ahead proceed with uh programming if
it's
not if it's reading any
fault we can quick erase the
DTC but looks like everything's okay
right
now okay see 84% 88 so everything looks
good let's go read pin
code turn the ignition off and turn the
hazard let's turn it
off turn the hazard so the hazard is
flashing please make sure you have Wi-Fi
this is connected to Wi-Fi
okay see the Wi-Fi is connected Ed on my
screen so communicating with vehicle
please wait for about about 1 to 10
minutes there's let's most likely go 10
minutes but if it's sometimes is faster
so what I can do I'm going to take a
pause until I'll come back with this one
because it's communicating right
now okay so that's about like four
minutes you get a password 6235
let's go key learning
guided go
start to learn program Keys you have to
erase key first so we're going to have
to erase the key first okay that's fine
if that's how it
works key number
two a check pin code has been saved do
you want to reread no because we already
have a PIN code
turn the ignition off and turn on the
hazard flasher please make sure ignition
is off wir device laptop cell phone
being process do you want to continue
yes let's go
continue 6235 press
okay please check if that's correct
press
okay hold the proximity near the center
console or stop start
button press the unlock button complete
the procedure for 30 seconds hold the
proximity key near to the center console
or stop start
button repeat to press press the unlock
button say press
it and press
okay do that and
lock I'm pressing down
please complete the following remaining
repeat repeatly press and release the
unlock button
approximately so
repeatedly that's the unlock
button so
closer I've been pressing for
that one's
failed
yes remove the Cent key prepare for
another key to be programmed Place into
the ignition if the car has a key slck
so let's check if there is a key slot
PR okay with this
one put it right
here press the unlock Buton
okay that one is done it didn't get me
any notification that it was processed
keeps saying it's program failed but
check this
out this one works so I'm going to put
this on top the
car so both keys on top of the car so
it's not sensing
it see that key FB not detected
but when I grab one I'm grab this
one I want to start and no
problem see that let me try the second
one let me put it on top of the car
start
it so this is no key fob again it won't
start let me get the original
one this the original
one and that thing start
that's fine guys everything's good this
one is saying it's failed but it does
program to the
car um let's go ahead check the remote
part if it
works
so
lock unlock
Works alarm
works and let's try the remote start
maybe you need to lock it first then
theote
start see if it works
unlock there you
go oh it's Hood the hood is open let me
close the hood hood was open let's go
try it
again hold it maybe double double press
there you go the car
started all right guys everything is
done things is perfectly good I'm going
go ahead cut the key fob in it I mean
cut the emergency key
and it should be done and this one we
got it done with um the km
100 Auto km 100 for this 2016 Dodge
Durango RT all right guys hope you like
this video Don't forget to like And
subscribe